yes Arafat was a hero of the Palestinian
uprising against the Israeli occupation
he's one of the founders of the
political faction Fatah and fought with
the organization against Israel in the
aim of liberating Palestine Fatah gain
control of the Palestine Liberation
Organization with Arafat as its leader
he eventually signed the Oslo Accords
with Israeli Prime Minister Yitzhak
Rabine in September 1993 which created
the promise of peace but 26 26 years
later there's still no resolution to the
israel-palestine conflict and settlement
expansion continues Arafat died in 2004
from what was reported to be a
month-long illness but an al jazeera
investigation in 2012 found Arafat was
poisoned by radioactive toxins Yossi
Beilin is a former minister of justice
and Israel and joins us now from Tel
Aviv thank you so much for your time so
that moment in 1993 the Oslo Accords
there obviously there are critics that
would say it was flawed but it was it
was an inflection point since then is it
clear to you that the two-state solution
is dead well what do you say I know it
is not there is no alternative I mean
there is no one state solution neither
for the Palestinians and no for Israel
both people's deserve their own states
and I believe that eventually this will
happen and not in hundred years from now
but much less than that yes Arafat as it
was now said it was an icon was a
revolutionist and modern state builder
that it is for sure he made something
which was unique and they will
remembered for that by bringing the
Palestinian issue today to the world
knowledge a high on the agenda much more
than than before him and that was of
course very important for the
Palestinian people for us as Israelis
his decision in 88 and the National
Brazilian Council a decision in Algiers
it was very very important this was I
believe they the real milestone in which
the Palestinian leadership admitted
it's mistake by rejecting the partition
UN resolution in 47 rather than having
already then two states and preventing
the wall of 48 and the verification on
the of this small for the Palestinians
and also for the Israelis but mainly for
the Palestinians and for the Arab states
eventually in 88 he said okay 47 should
be the the basis and we are ready to
accept UN resolution 242 and to change
our policy and that was the opening for
the relations between the PLO and the
United States and later on when I began
the Oslo process that was a at the basis
also for our for our process which was a
distorted by by the extremists on both
sides who were not ready for peace okay
on for a partition let me ask you this
you said that that the the two-state
solution isn't dead perhaps the idea of
it isn't but are we further away from it
than we were 15 years ago I don't think
so I think that it is the other way
around
in many ways the toasted solution became
a consensus both in Palestine in Israel
and in the world it was not the case
years ago okay the the Palestinians
obviously are are more fragmented more
divided than they were before do you see
any type of disbelief do you see any
type of pathway for there to be a
unifying leader that at least Arafat was
at one time is that is that necessary is
that that type of figure called for well
I believe that a Palestinian unity is
important not only for the Palestinians
but also for Israel I believe that for
those who believe in peace the division
in the palestinian camp is devastating
and they i hope that it would be
possible but of course on a basis which
will respect the decisions the
legitimate and former decisions of the
Palestinian leadership yes even thank
you so much for your insight we
appreciate it joining us from Tel Aviv